Poland says it won't give Ukraine any
more weapons they've been allies for a
long time but they're now locked in a
diplomatic dispute over grain Poland
says it's banned Ukrainian grain Imports
to protect the interests of its own
Farmers Ukraine says it'll Lodge a
complaint or the World Trade
Organization we're going to cross to
zasi he's in Sumi in northeastern
Ukraine this is all happening really
pretty fast what's behind it
Z well this is something that has
definitely been building for some time
but this fracture between these two very
close allies easily Ukraine's closest
partner in the war against Russia if not
broadly definitely on Continental Europe
Poland has been Ukraine's closest
partner this fracture will be something
that will be of of serious concern to
all of the countries supporting Ukraine
in this conflict with Russia it has been
building for some time and it is around
this graind deal now what what what
we're looking at is grain that was meant
to be going out through the Black Sea
because that those ports are closed
because of the Russian invasion and
because of Russian controls over the
Black Sea that has now been crossing
over land and much of that not meant to
be stopping in Europe has been finding
its way the European market something
that those countries Poland now being
the prime one have have tried to push
back against now from the Polish point
of view we are seeing this disagreement
coming up just ahead of national
election next month the prime minister
no doubt trying to shore up support
among ruler conservative voters but what
the ukrainians will be saying is that
this dismisses the fact that Ukraine is
a country at War its ports are unable to
function normally and not making
allowances for that goes against the
spirit of being an ally in this conflict
now it certainly is something that comes
as a as a surprise Poland took in
millions of refugees millions of
displaced ukrainians at the at the
height of the war at the beginning of
the war it has been providing weapons
and support tactical support as well
some of the most high numbers of
volunteers foreign volunteers that have
come to Ukraine as part of the war
effort have come from Poland so this
fracture is certainly something that
will have a broad ramifications and no
doubt will put pressure on Ukraine's
other allies to step up in terms of
their weapons supplies especially the
United States President Biden is
expected to make a decision on long
range ballistic missile systems called
attam that would help Ukraine uh Target
deep inside Russia that will certainly
be something that Ukraine's president in
the United States now will be bringing
to the Forefront of his conversations
Zan I mentioned that you're in in Sumi
in northeastern Ukraine and that's a
region that's playing quite a unique
role as the war is going on between uh
Russia and Ukraine tell us a little bit
more about where you
are that's EX exactly right just in the
last few days since we've been here this
week we've noticed an uptick in the
number of air raid sirens and the number
of attacks uh not just in the region but
broadly across the country as if to
punctuate Poland's decision this morning
we woke up to reports of dozens of
missiles fired across the country east
to west and much of the border is is is
very tightly controlled but here in the
Sumi region right at the border with
Russia there is an example of Ukraine
and Russia in a kind of quiet
cooperation and an example of what it
means for civilians caught up in the
fighting when the two sides are able to
put aside differences and prioritize
humanitarian needs